Що може вчинити Захід для покарання Росії за вторгнення в Україну та для зупинки Путіна від подальшої агресії?
Після першого шоку від брутальності дій Кремля Європейський Союз,
Велика сімка і НАТО активно обговорюють подальший план дій.
Північно-Атлантичний альянс має намір зміцнювати свої східні кордони та збільшувати присутність там своїх військ.
Альянс також активізує плани оборони для союзників, повідомив генсек альянсу Єнс Столтенберг
після надзвичайної наради постійних представників країн-членів НАТО.
Це навмисне, холоднокровне та завчасно заплановане вторгнення.
Поприбрехню, запереченняі дезінформацію, світ чітко бачить наміри Кремля.
Російські лідери несуть повну відповідальність за свої безрозсудні дії та втрачені життя.
Союзники по НАТО найрішучіше засуджують вторгнення Росії в Україну.
Це кричуще порушення міжнародного права, акт агресії проти суверенної,
незалежної та мирної країни та серйозна загроза євроатлантичній безпеці.
Столтенберг додав, що понад 100 військових літаків приведено у стан
підвищеної боєготовності у відповідь на напад Росії на Україну.
Водночас він кілька разів уникав запитання, чи не роздумує НАТО таки надіслати війська до України.
У підсумку він заявив:
Ні, в Україні немає жодних бойових підрозділів НАТО, взагалі немає військ НАТО.
Ми дали чітко зрозуміти, що не маємо жодних планів або намірів вводити війська НАТО в Україну.
Натомість ми вже збільшили і збільшуємо присутність військ НАТО у східній частині Альянсу.
На 25 лютого НАТО скликав саміт щодо ситуації в Україні, на якому країни-члени обговорять подальші дії.
НАТО нині важливо уникнути прямої, навіть ненавмисної
військової конфронтації з Росією, вважають німецькі експерти.
Україна не є членом НАТО. При цьому в західному таборі прозвучали заяви про те,
що у разі такого нападу з боку Росії країни Альянсу постачатимуть українцям зброю,
що вони розмірковують про навчання українських військових на території країн НАТО.
Утім, у довгостроковій перспективі, на думку деяких військових експертів,
НАТО не вдасться уникнути конфронтації з Росією.
Путін буде звинувачувати Захід, казатиме, що все це з вини НАТО,
що Захід переконав Україну чинити опір Росії.
А ще він застосовуватиме засоби, які в минулому робили дієвими військові погрози - ядерну загрозу,
щоб примусити Захід зупинити підтримку України чи зупинити
подальшу партизанську війну там, що ми, звісно, не можемо і не будемо робити.
Але це його зле мислення, яке видно з його промов.
Виходячи з цього, ми рано чи пізно зіткнемося з конфронтацією з Росією у військовій площині.
І це настільки серйозно, наскільки звучить.
У своєму зверненні в ніч на 24 лютого президент Путін оголосив про початок війни проти України,
погрозивши при цьому, що - цитата - "прямий напад на Росію призведе
до розгрому та жахливих наслідків для потенційного агресора".
Експерт Кюн ставиться до цієї загрози дуже серйозно.
Ми стикалися з подібними абсолютно неприйнятними ядерними загрозами і в минулому,
наприклад, у зв'язку з незаконною анексією Криму Росією у 2014 році.
Проте я сподіваюся, що російська сторона, і не лише російський президент, діятиме тут досить раціонально,
бо застосування ядерної зброї, звісно, змінить усе, і це означатиме, що світ опиниться на межі ядерної війни.
Я думаю, що всі хочуть запобігти цьому.
Але якщо ще раз послухати промову Володимира Путіна, то напрошується питання:
наскільки притомним є цей російський лідер?
Наразі Захід має надати Україні всебічну підтримку, кажуть експерти.
Вони не виключають, що Берлін навіть, можливо, перегляне свою позицію щодо постачання Києву оборонних озброєнь.
Приміром, міністр оборони Латвії Артіс Пабрікс заявив про необхідність
"негайних і масштабних санкцій" проти Росії і закликав Німеччину дозволити надати Україні зброю.
Спершу ми повинні запровадити негайні та масштабні санкції проти держави-агресора Росії.
По-друге, ми повинні надати українській армії та українському населенню масштабну допомогу,
щоб вони змогли перемогти.
Нашим моральним обов’язком є ​​підтримка гуманітарною допомогою, але також летальною зброєю.
Я не думаю, що може бути занадто багато підтримки Україні, як не може бути занадто багато санкцій.
Хочу звернутися до німецького суспільства: будь ласка, відкрийте очі!
Будь ласка, дозвольте також українцям отримати летальну зброю!
Тому що ситуація зараз зовсім інша.
У четвер лідери Європейського Союзу зібралися на позачерговий саміт, щоб узгодити санкції проти РФ.
Мета Росії - не лише Донбас, мета - не лише Україна.
Мета - стабільність у Європі та весь міжнародний світовий порядок.
І ми притягнемо президента Путіна до відповідальності за це.
Пізніше ми представимо на затвердження європейських лідерів пакет масштабних та прицільних санкцій.
За допомогою цього пакету ми націлимося на стратегічні сектори російської економіки,
блокуючи їхній доступ до технологій та ринків, які є ключовими для Росії.
Ми послабимо економічну основу Росії та її здатність до модернізації.
Крім того, ми заморозимо російські активи в Європейському Союзі та
зупинимо доступ російських банків до європейських фінансових ринків.
Для усього цього немає жодного виправдання. Це війна Путіна.
Я сказав сьогодні вранці у телефонній розмові президенту Зеленському:
у ці важкі години ми повністю солідарні з Україною та її громадянами.
Ціль наших санкцій - чітко дати зрозуміти російському керівництву:
за цю агресію вони заплатять гірку ціну.
Вони побачать, що Путін зі своєю війною зробив величезну помилку.
Не заперечуючи необхідність термінових санкцій, експерти все ж сумніваються,
що вони допоможуть швидко зупинити російську агресію.
На жаль, я мушу бути дуже песимістичним.
Санкції - це завжди довготривала ціль. Вони покликані змінити політику в довгостроковій перспективі.
А ми має справу з негайною війною. Тим не менше російську агресію Україна одна не зможе зупинити.
Це має бути нашим найбільшим інтересом, щоб стримати Путіна, наскільки це тільки можливо.
Усіма засобами, які ми маємо в наших руках.
Тим часом голова Єврокомісії також запевнила, що ЄС готовийприйняти біженців з України
та надати країні негайну гуманітарну підтримку.